bo Derek that chair on there yes yes
welcome in this is mark Normand hey
convenient exam Jordan Harbinger one of
the top podcasters in the world and this
is Jim Norton she knows you know Jim
travels with the penis pump so we all
have I do in my life we all have our
credits here welcome we were reading up
about you before you came in and with
all this like you you got married you
met your husband at one point when you
were 16 and you guys had to leave the
country that's fascinating to me that
you guys left and then came was your
family okay with that or no no no I met
him when I was 16 at 17 we were overseas
making a movie and I don't know what
happened we ended up together and we
couldn't come home till I was 18 oh okay
watch boy you did watch movie I was
called him once upon a time is this
before Orca it was before Orca oh that's
the first one listed I don't think I
don't think that one did one time I was
listed on your IMDB no I don't think it
didn't get released oh it was a well
maybe it did I don't know it was a long
time ago it was a tiny little
independent film one they weren't Sheik
then little independent films and right
there was no sort of it's just a digital
release there was no independent film
festival right so what happened you had
to call home and go look I'm not coming
back for well my mom was with me as my
chaperone oh how did you break it when
you're 17 you feel like you know
everything of course you're making the
right decision for your whole traveling
I'm with this exciting older man it was
it was an artist it was fantastic do you
but now I look back on photos and yeah
can we see those dude take that and like
look at that the way sort of the
mistakes that kids make in Hollywood now
that are 16 17 year old like those
mistakes get covered tremendously now
because of kind of the culture that
we're in and TMZ social media and all
that you look at it and go like well
yeah I mean this is what happens when
you're 16 and 17 we all do dumb [ __ ]
of course yeah and it might the only
saving grace my husband was
sober so I didn't get into drugs and all
that oh that wasn't part of it right did
you like when I was just lucky I think I
would have done it all do you intend
that much older did you guys have
anything in common or after a while I
like but do you like mentally or no I
mean obviously I was I was absorbing and
learning from him like a sponge I won't
lie but I I do have some strengths and
some core and we were very compatible
funny enough yeah it's weird right I'm
kind of a gypsy we traveled the world
together and I'm selfish so it was fun
plus there's also probably something
intoxicating about like I know normally
this doesn't work for people but for us
we're different and this is special Yeah
right it's very romantic
right it is did you like Richard Harris
so I got to know minorca and then I got
to hire him I was producing a Tarzan
movie what are they doing Tarzan he
played my father in Tarzan he was great
and a great friend to the end I was just
I was just in London last week at the
Savoy Hotel I went in had a drink just
to remember him because that's where he
lived at the end of his life he lived in
hotel he was a big drinker it he was
good and then he was and and and quite a
violent one that's what I think I heard
yeah yeah he was one of those bad boys
yeah shot him
I heard Robert Shaw was like that on the
set in Jaws like you know one day you
get a great take in the next day then
not as good no he was behaving but then
he would he would have one rough night
films I think on Orca and Tarzan he so
you kind of be waiting like knowing I
know we're gonna have one night wine
rough one once we get past it it's gonna
be a whole good it isn't that old-school
Hollywood a punch somebody whatever
because it was both times it was um an
assistant director did he hit yes but
that guy you know sort of pushed it
let's go have a drink you know it was
sort of he deserved it right huh we all
knew that he was on
wagon right they just wanted the story
out of it like all let's see if we can
rile them up right experienced dick he
and pet names you know yeah in the face
like that or no everybody likes to be
loved no did he like being called dick
or a little pet names or did he was okay
with it he was okay with it how did you
handle like because I remember obviously
every you've heard this a million times
from guys but growing up of course you
know when ten came out I mean you were
every guy was thinking about you I mean
how did you handle just going from being
a regular actress to this you're this
iconic figure overnight the business
just sort of hit me by surprise and all
of that fame hit me by surprise so you
just deal with that day-to-day
I had no grand plan no I didn't have
agents or I hadn't even fantasized about
it so I was so unprepared like it's not
even a possibility this isn't one of the
things that would happen preparation if
you dream I'm going to be a movie star
that's some kind of preparation just
dealt with it day to day I had a strong
good relationship that was more
important to me than the business so
it's been fantastic the business was
Dudley Moore a delight some great
legends and and some really incredible
men yeah well I mean you work with
Dudley Moore you work with Chris Farley
Chris Farley um Anthony Quinn yeah
fantastic
he's Holly Quinn I mean Anthony Hopkins
yes sir
change of seasons Sir Anthony what was
this Holly because there's all this me
too movement now we're but people are
being kind of called out for the casting
couch and hitting on actresses or here
or was it different then or was it just
one of those things where you knew it
was a part of the business you avoided
it when you could and no one talked
about it everybody talked about it it
was part of the business it was just
accepted and established as part of the
business and it wasn't necessary it gets
complicated this because it was so
accepted for so long and now we're
seeing this hasn't
isn't gradually fading away we just came
on like a freight train and things are
changing so and there is no excuse for
sexual abuse but there's something weird
about Hollywood and people will do will
kill for money
they'll kill for power you put Fame that
just makes all those things very small
Fame is just so much more important to
people and they'll kill everybody for it
so you have this this commodity yeah
that that women and men start to barter
to it's very complicated ended well yeah
I mean I think that that's the thing
that a lot of people don't talk about
they when they talk about me too and
everything they don't talk about the
elements that make it so specific in
Hollywood and it's that it's the that's
power dynamics and they and the fame and
Fame everything is such a big part of it
but I feel like so often that Hollywood
almost wants to protect itself and go
like no this is a global problem in a
world problem and it is a problem
outside of Hollywood but not like it is
inside of it it's different from they
say oh every corporation every business
atmosphere it's not it's different there
how did you how did you feel when sort
of the insides of the business really
started to become fodder for everybody
when the gossip industry really started
to take over and in every single thing
that celebrities did started to get
monitored and you were responsible for
every single word that came out of your
mouth at all times the gossip was always
there
you were you were owned by a studio that
helped negotiate a little bit between
the old gossip columnist so that was
always there what's different is there's
no separation now between your public
and private life right and it's the
actors themselves that are creating this
and it's hard for them to complain later
when something comes out that they don't
like because they've been selling you
know I I came up at a time and it was
always important to me my private life
is my private life
I kept that separate that's all blurred
now yeah you know they're making they're
making fame and money off of it so but
they have to accept that the Bad's gonna
come with it - we were just talking
about social media but right before you
walked in and how like you know even
people who have made a good living off
of it and that it's helping them and it
promotes them and everything are
starting to realize like this is the
thing that is completely blurring the
line that once you become Instagram
famous that's not like I'm just famous
on Instagram like you're expected to
share your entire life yeah and to
compare and to allow people to judge and
and literally judge like we're gonna
click this and say if we like it or we
don't like it and it's kind of
incredible the people have voluntarily
put themselves in that position it is
it's it's it was shocking to me at first
but now I understand it it's it is it is
you you can't argue right you ever wish
you weren't famous like you ever out and
people just like I wish nobody know who
I was right now it's for me alone I kind
of have that now I you know I'm not so
relevant as I was I used to not be able
to walk down the street leave a hotel
room and now I it's it's great oh yeah
yeah if I get in trouble I'll find
someone who will recognize help me out
here so you're at that fun level of Fame
it's great where it's like you still get
the sort of adulation from fans yes I do
this and then I can still go into museum
and enjoy a place or a restaurant or
walk down the street and be anonymous
and the people recognized you were
probably polite oh yes they're not mania
but when in like 1980 or 81 no I
couldn't go anywhere you see without the
active you are you still over there
you saw the air about you like when you
walked in I was in the lobby and I was
like I don't I'm not sure that is but
it's cheese famous and of course they
came and sat down your sister and I was
like okay that proves it people like
circle thing what would you do because I
heard Henry Winkler like when when Happy
Days was on used to have
you hear that five bodyguards when
you're not I mean I do how many people
you travel with would you have to have
at least one person with you would you
have a couple yeah it was funny when I
first travel the first time I traveled
alone all by myself summarize because
from the time I was 22 I was always with
someone if not a lot of people and it
wasn't it wasn't that I was a diva or
that I demanded all this attention
it was just physically impossible to get
to you or was it weird to do stuff by
yourself like like I kind of like I
always wanted when the president is done
and the first time you sit in traffic do
you realize like wow this sucks
right you didn't like it right bad seed
I mean it's just it's it's an adjustment
you you when you first like travel by
yourself and what point in your life is
that I think time I traveled by myself I
was 16 okay okay so it wasn't it was
before yeah but then from 22 on for
years and years and years I didn't you
did a so you know you get met at the
plane with a car right was there a point
to like cuz you were working a lot was
there a point where you're like I'm not
getting as much as I used to or did you
stop wanting stuff was you're like [ __ ]
I want to do something but I'm just not
able to grab something you know this
month or this year I'm still shocked
anyone hires me so I'm not just saying
that I think it's a miracle I I stumbled
into a business that everybody wants
yeah
everybody everybody would kill for it
right and they sweat and they toil and
they labor try to get the tiniest part
and here I was just offered the whole
industry how did it happen this happened
I was in a movie you know Blake ever
retired me for a movie called ten and it
was a tiny part I'm in the movie about
10 minutes and overnight well I could do
anything I wanted in the industry you
could write is that when you started
producing and doing stuff behind the
scenes yeah and is that a survival
mechanism or is it just I'm curious
about this part I was making little
films with my husband before you know
$60,000 movies and then all of a sudden
I became famous and I was being offered
all this stuff and being pushed and
pulled and then somebody said why don't
you go make films with your husband you
just be in
and when you get a lot more money to
more than 60,000 to make them and that
sounded like fun
did he ever get like you know because
you're dating this beautiful you know
girl at 18 or 17 and all of a sudden
your wife is the most famous woman on
earth like literally the most
sought-after did he ever get insecure or
possessive or no so now I don't want you
to go work with him or how did he handle
it obviously had a lot of advice he was
in the business his parents were in
silent films he was a big movie star he
was married to Ursula Andress the first
Bond the sensuous nurse this story's not
horrifying my dad took me to a drive-in
and there was the one movie playing and
the late movie was the sensuous his dad
and his friend be right you wouldn't
sexy
but I I said I want to see this think if
we're not staying for the sensuous Terje
don't watch the sensuous nurse with his
28 year-old son okay he knew to have a
wife that everybody was a man he's only
it's real only people think he
controlled my career and ruined my
career
the only advice he really gave me that
stuck was just because everyone else
wants it you don't have to make sure you
really want this and I sort of took it
on my own terms
why they think you ruined your career
because I people thought I should have
gone on to be a bigger star done better
movies because you're making your own
movies instead of doing the big good but
everybody made their money back and a
good profit so when you're having a good
time I had a great time you ever wish is
there one that you were offered and
didn't take that you like I kind of wish
I would have tried that one there were
probably a couple I thought of one
yesterday I can't think of it right now
somebody I wished I'd had worked with
but kind of right especially with as
much as you were able to accomplish
anyway like I mean what do you know
honestly did you get a lot of weirdo
offers like guys saying I'll give you
200 grand to do my birthday party
not too many when my husband was alive
people were afraid of him he was a real
tough guy so that's why I don't have a
lot of casting Kent couch
stories I have a few well that not
nothing really bad because they were
afraid of my butt so there was a couple
that would try now would you when
something like that would happen where a
guy will look I got this you know
whatever method they used to try to
sleep with you would you say I'll tell
my husband or how would you defuse that
most of them didn't even try it with me
but when they did you know I was you
know I was brought up you kick him in
the nuts
they were not back off were they ever
would never point where you had to just
really use that foot yeah twice I'm not
very tall so it's not easy but just the
attempt is usual even if you hit the
thigh or something it wasn't aggressive
or violent it was just grabby touchy
rough you know you kind of kicked them
and yeah back off right that that is the
unit kicking in the notch is the
universal symbol yeah back off yeah was
it ever heart like was there ever an
actor you're working with like I love my
husband I'm not gonna but like this is a
hard one to not take the offer good
question I've never had that question
nope come on beautiful men but I know
I'm just that kind of girl if you can
hold on for you that's the important but
you weren't there was knowing that you
were like Albert Reynolds I quit you
know oh he was a hairy chest you're a
fan mark was Burnet difficult guy
because I like the only thing I based it
on was his appearance on The Tonight
Show and this is much later in his life
where I think he was a little bit
insecure as a star had waned quite a bit
and there's this interaction that he had
with mark summers from double dare and
he clearly felt disrespected that this
dopey kids game show host felt like he
was on the same level and they had this
really like
uncomfortable throwing water each other
hostile thing was he always like that or
do you think that's something that
developed later you know my stepfather
was one of the greatest stunt men who
did a lot of his movies stunt
coordinator and so and they had a good
relationship but I just think that you
know he it's a tough business and I
think he did some abuse problems abuse
problems and that'll distort you will
you stepfathers I'm sorry was a stunt
quarter who helped Burt Reynolds who
worked on who did some of his movies
yeah we do deliverance didn't do
deliverance I know he did Hooper and
he's even in his real name and his
character which is the what stuntmen
which is the one where he burrows backs
out of that parking garage in Chicago
was something Sharky's machine yeah I
think Bobby did that he'll be bass was
my stepfather yeah Wow
yeah terminator terminator
that's amazing he was a stunt guy too
stunt coordinator and stunt man yes Wow
how many injuries did he suffer like
what everybody come home like with
broken arms and broken legs
yeah and in the end it caused him to
have Parkinson's how come I guess brain
injuries or smacking his head I didn't
know that could actually give you part
yeah I guess
mama dolly yep yeah oh yeah what do you
has he did a lot of the car flips Bobby
oh wow sorry
it's literally like people would be like
well how does this not work well you sit
and you're in a car accident five times
a day for the next two weeks
right yeah and there's flip see those
guys still get hurt and safety
regulations were a lot different than
they were then back when he was doing
you know the sixties and seventies yeah
yeah yeah
what are you promoting - could we we
haven't even got you doing what is the
red dress collection Fashion Show
Fashion Week here in New York you
probably know that obviously it's kind
of our forte yes Vera Wang this shirt
American Heart Association roomful of
guys you probably know all the symptoms
for a heart attack
a heart attack heart disease is the
leading cause of death in women and most
women don't know it one in three women
will die of heart related disease
so awareness is really important and so
there's a big fashion show tomorrow
night and we all wear wear red all the
girls and guys and we I get to walk
Flynn the winner of a Westminster Dog
Show runway the real dog a new focus on
how pets especially dogs help our health
they motivate us keep us more fit you
live longer if you have a pet and most
of us who have pets know this
instinctively already but science of
Medicine has validated it yeah whenever
I've got old relatives that the dog dies
I'm like we got to get you new right
away exactly you know that that was the
thing that keeps you going like no we're
getting a puppy in here not an old dog
like we're getting a brand-new puppy
yeah one life in this palace to walk
around and around you got to walk around
clean up you got to feed it oh I should
get up and go to the store that's where
I screwed up my grandmother's dog died I
got her a fish how'd you get involved
with this cause like if somebody you
love died this way or cuz usually it's
something personal that will attach
somebody to it I have personal in my
family definitely personal stories in me
myself in particular but I also have a
line of pet products called bo Derek pet
care and we support retired military
working dogs I work on wildlife
trafficking issues so I have an
association all you do with the animals
working with animals and what are their
benefit for their welfare what do you
think of how easily those help dog vests
are passed out these dolls it's like I
mean I don't have a problem with that I
get excited when there's a dog on the
plane but the cap and I love it yeah
every time a dog walks in I get excited
but yeah I brought a Rottweiler on
nobody Cheers it was a boy
but there are people that that get
annoyed that the the help dogs that it's
given out a lot more easily now that
it's not necessarily just a physical
thing but a mental thing and anybody can
go and we don't like that you know I was
a sports commissioner for seven years so
wow you've done it all
Racing Commissioner in California Wow
wait for like you NASCAR horse racing
horse race yeah right vice chair and so
I'm kind of a stickler for rules is
there a horse is there a harm in abusing
that rule it's just unfair to the people
who play by the rules I see yes and I'm
kind of that sort of person and so I
think we should just change the rules
allow the pants right where a certain
amount of pets and you sign up early
what for it like you do for a good seat
right or something they should just come
to terms so it's fair for everybody
throw a mean Economy Plus or so I don't
draw the line at ducks and peacocks and
pigs right so you think if somebody's
like no I need this peacock is my
comfort animal you're like look I love
animals I love people relax you don't
need a peek okay I don't know that might
I might be wrong there maybe maybe you
should bring a peacock I don't know I
have a pet that comforts me you know
it's a Japanese Hornet and I bring on a
flight it's got to be trained though
that's the thing is like people will go
oh well this is my comfort upgrayedd
obeys it's it's sitting there quietly
it's not yapping it's not biting people
but when someone's like this is my
comfort thing I got yesterday and I
printed this paper off on the Internet
and now it's like eating people's food
it's clearly not trained you just bought
this and then you bought a vest and now
you're trying to be like it's it's the
law you're not I'm going to get rid of
babies smart if you have an airline
delay like delays suck but if you the
three-hour delay and the dog is hang out
on the bathroom and everybody can bring
a pet on there's like a whole Plane full
of dogs that need to go to the bathroom
and there's a three-hour bathroom and
throw a wee pad down can you do that
yeah why not
what about pink cats can cats be comfort
animals because I feel like no
I never met a cat that's trust were
there any social yeah even cats that
like are nice in moments you know you
could see it in their eyes like they got
their nails they got their their fangs
you know at a moment's notice if
anything about their life is is asked in
a disgusting cat like I love cats his
cat was a pile of money to get my cat to
a lumberyard because it got were yard
well lumberyard specifically just threw
it in the lumber yard no we found a nice
lumberyard that would take it and it
could chase raccoons and do wild cat
stuff because my wife went off birth
control and in post coital moments my
cat went into attack mode
yeah and my wife said we can't continue
to have post-coital moments and the cat
and I said cats gotta go boy this is
important to a relationship my opinion
we have a cougar here yeah so you know
that was that was my experience maybe
it's because we named the cat bruiser I
don't know maybe there's an awful animal
so he's very biased yes I am I had a bad
experience I loved the cat very much and
it is very difficult and that's why we
found a great lumberyard for it but a
lot of mice happened we were worried
about it and we called the you know
worried about the cat and on the way out
the guy was like yeah we get a raccoon
every now and then that should be fine
right and we're like oh my god what are
we doing what are we doing and so we
called the young Burt lumberyard the
next day and said how's bruiser ba-ba-ba
and they said well the good news is we
don't have a raccoon problem anymore
because bruiser changed all the raccoons
out of here and I said you know what if
a cat is overpowering raccoons yeah it's
not meant to live in an apartment yes
and then Sam and his wife showed up and
the cats slammed the door in their face
and then wept quietly well you know look
it's really nice to meet you too I mean
your husband your husband your boyfriend
John oh you have a job yeah you guys
have been together forever yeah yeah
like 19 years yeah I like him a lot he's
uh he was in that shows Bobby Kelly show
that he was in with
yeah I'll show you at the premiere of
that and I wanted to say hello
I'm very rarely too nervous to approach
somebody was actually too nervous to
walk up and say hello do the restraining
order with the husband I don't you know
does he still have sex in the City fans
approached him yes because people are
obsessed with that show and he's like so
I mean he's a giant and he's instantly
recognizable he's just bigger than life
right and in any way and then that show
and northern exposure yeah what do you
mean in any way what he's bigger than
life bigger than life in any way
well he's six foot oh just always a
physical Renia singh is when he when he
and chris know they're together Oh what
does he drop when they walk in a room
yes they are bigger than life they fill
the doorway anyway he's an amazing both
of you you find yourself in this
relationship and you both have these
roles that no matter how many years go
by people can't let them go they just
stick with people forever it's pretty
rare right it is rare yeah you got yes
right you got to be a certain kind of
guide to to date bowed out you know you
can't you can't be a guy hey Norton as
it's known you can't she would not
choose that be too insecure and I'd be
too easy to have you think you get
jealous do it depend yes see body
shaming not good not good mark not good
do you think sex symbols are made
differently now than they were back then
there was you there was Farrah Fawcett
like there was all these and now all of
a sudden you you know if you do like a
porn tape that gets leaked you're an
iconic figure please do one well we're
just as a society we're just consuming
celebrities actors all our pop stars
were just consuming more yeah it was
going to movie was not so you didn't see
movies every night you didn't right
absorb so much of it so I la it's great
for the business it's thirsty for
content mm-hmm
so it's it's good for the business and
I'm just amazed these young people have
it together as much as they do yeah
yeah well you know I found it very
overwhelming some of them are having
struggle but that's part you struggle if
your whatever your job is right or
struggling to yeah like people who
aren't famous if you really put a camera
on them during their college years it's
not gonna be pretty this you just go
through it in public
exactly runs and family knowing it but
I'm amazed they have it so together cuz
it 22 I was neither not